Well,
good night,
Bach,
I haven't thought about
Shinoko,
Rou-kun and Uozumi-kun's feelings until now
What
are you talking about
?  I was asking him
so that I wouldn't have to add an answer Even though
I justified it in myself
I still can't forget about Hada-kun
But I thought I had sorted things out in my own way I
thought I'd try to be positive
But it was half-hearted
[Music] After
all, I'm
afraid of being
alone I know you're pulling back
I thought it would be fine I guess it's a good
fit
Wear it like that
[Music]
I'll
wait too  I
may have refused it once, but it's selfish, but
there was a pushy like 6, and there was
also a Uzumi country.
Good evening
Neighbor
Kusagi It's not like talking while standing in a place like this
Change the place or go around the
house It's messy